早速べきですけど皆さん
留学ってすべきだと思いますか
したいと思いますか
なぜそう思うかちょっとこんなことを考え
ながらみなさんに話を聞いていただきたい
なと思うんですが
こちらのグラフ見ていただいて
留学生の数
ピンクのグラフ
日本に入ってくる外国人留学生の数を表し
ています増えてますねねんねん逆に日本
から外に出る留学生の数減ってます
ここ10年間で3割以上減っている
すごい減り方ですね
よく内向きだなと言われますけど皆さん
そうですかね海外興味ないですか
どうですか
ちょっと
他のデータを見ていただくと
a これ
国税庁の民間給与実態調査というものなん
ですけど1997年以降日本人の平均9が
減ってるんですね17年くらい
失われた20年なんて言われてますけど
減っているさらに
日本の人口皆さん入ってるの知ってますね
少子高齢化進んでます
これを見ると人口も給料も減ってて将来
不安だって言う人多いと思いますけど
ちょっと視点を変えてみて
世界に目を向けてみるとどうか
世界の人口増えてますね特にアジア
アフリカ
これらの国って経済の成長しています
もう世界に目を向けざるを得ない状況
どんどんできてきているんですね日本に
行ってもどんどん外国人入ってきます
グローバル化が進んでいる
そんな中で留学経験ってより重要性を増し
ていると私は思っています
ここからですねちょっと私の経験に基づい
て今回のテーマである出会いインフ減少
演歌無料
それについてちょっとお話しさせて
いただきたいです
まず私が留学を決意した理由
中学校の頃の先輩との出会いなんですね私
仙台の中学校に通ってまして私の姉も兄も
友達もみんな
そのまま仙台で進学してたので自分も
当たり前のように高校仙台でいくもんだと
思ってました受験するもんだと
思ってたのが中学校の先輩がですね突然
ニュージーランドで行っちゃったんですね
高校留学でそれを聞いたときに衝撃を受け
ました
今まで仙台から出ることすら考えたことが
なかった14年間
なのに海を越えて進学しちゃった人が目の
前にいたときにすごい衝撃だったんですね
そんな選択肢が人生あるんだってそんな
ことできるんだって衝撃を受けてそれから
も海外に行くことしか考えられなくなった
んですね
で親に相談したら親も理解があっていいぞ
と自分から来たいって言うんだったら言っ
てみろって言うので行かせてもらえること
になったんですね
でニュージーランド615歳で初めての
海外ニュージーランドに行きました
でいろんな出会いがあったんです
ニュージーランドでニュージーランドって
皆さんご存知かんですけどすごくた民族の
国家で白人だけじゃなくて原住民のマオリ
族だったりとかアジアからの移民留学生も
たくさんいるんですね私行ったときにまだ
英語力がなかったんで留学生のための英語
コースみたいな入るとまぁ必然的に留学生
の友達いっぱいできますよね
最初に少し衝撃的だったのがその留学生
たちとの出会いなんですね
まあ当たり前のようにいろんな国の人たち
アジアの人多かったですけど
いて歴史の話とかそういうのが出てきます
よ
そうすると
どういう話になるかというとやっぱり歴史
の問題とか話してるとみんな意見を言うん
ですね俺はこうもう私はこうもうお前は
どう思うて聞かれたときにはつ何も答え
られなかったそれにショックを受けたん
です何年に何が起きたみたいので記者
ちょっと知ってましたけど
意見惹かれたの初めて何も答えられなかっ
たんですね凄く感じさせられたのが自分の
意見を持ってない世界で全然議論の場に
すら参加できないんだってすごく気づかさ
れたんですねなんか知識があるだけでダメ
なんだなって意見を持ってないと話の中に
も入れなかったんです
すごくそれは私の学び方の考え方変え
させる出来事でしたね
これからそういう学び方しなきゃ自分の
意見を持たないかと思いました
さらにですね
これ私が高校3年生のときの写真なんです
けど途中でニュージーランドであの田舎の
町に変更しまして日本人1人かいない環境
ですごくいい環境で英語力も族伸びたん
ですけどこの環境でですねこの私の仲良し
グループの写真なんですけど高校3年生に
なってくるとみんな当たり前のようにあの
進路を考えますよね
でニュージーランドって英語圏という特性
があるからかどうか彼ら当たり前のように
海外進学っていうのが選択肢に入ってるん
ですね俺はオーストラリアイギリス行く
たい
さらに彼ら目的意識も高いですねこれが
やりたいからオーストラリア軍な所に行く
んだってすごく目的意識を持っている
でそれを聞いたときに私また刺激を受けて
ですね自分は何やりたいんだろうと高校3
年生の時に考えた
その時からやっぱ企業将来したいなあって
なんとなく思ってたんでビジネスを
アメリカで学ぼうって決めたんですね
それでアメリカの大学に行くことを決め
ましたでまた親に相談してホヤも理解が
あるので後ろにいる保護者の方々もぜひ
いいか押して頂ければと思うんですま理解
のある方で自分でいきたいんだったら行っ
ていいぞということでアメリカ留学行ける
ことになったんですね
アメリカに行きます
でアメリカ
ここでも様々なでありました
すごく印象的な出会い多かったんですけど
その中でも印象的な出会いが一つあるん
ですね
まだ私がアメリカの大学行ったばっかりの
時入学してまだ12週間しか経ってない時
ですね
経済学のクラスに行ったんですね
そしたらクラスのみんなが何か提出してる
んです
何だろうと思ったら実はそれ提出しなきゃ
いけない課題がその日あったんですね
入学したばっかりの時にクラスでその課題
出されてたの私ちゃんと聞いてなかったの
が理解してなかったのか何もやってなかっ
たんですね
だからその課題当然ながら提出できなかっ
たんで0点取っちゃったんです
でアメリカの学校って
課題とか
出席とかっていうのすごく成績に響くん
ですね
だからそれがで出せなかったというの
すごく成績に日
で成績が悪過ぎたら退学ってこともあり
えるんですごく落ち込んだんですねまた
最初からつまづいちゃったんです大学では
もう十分やっていけないんじゃないか大学
の授業についていけないんじゃないか5
迫力のハンデもある家で食べないんじゃ
ないかと落ち込んでました
で次にクラスに行った時にもう落ち込んで
てもしょうがないなって思ってちょっと
気持ちを切り替えてもう人に頼ってでも
やろうと思ったんです
もう暮らす中で頭いい奴見つけてそいつに
たよっ
クラスで周りを見渡したらたまたま隣に
座ってたと思うとすごく頭よさそうで授業
中の33の太って
もう彼に頼ろうとウザがられてもいいから
全部機構って思ったんです決めてさっそく
彼に聞いてみたんですね今全然ちょっと
授業は買ってないから教えてくれないか
って
聞いてみたら衝撃的な一言が帰ってきたん
です
俺もは館でておいたんですね
を勝負を受けましたね彼に頼ろうと決めた
のにも俺もわかんないって言われたらでも
その一言のおかげで私パッと明るくなった
んですね彼のおかげで4年間やってき
たって言ってもいいぐらい
何かというと私多分無意識のうちに劣等感
感じてたんですねクラスのほかのみんなは
授業について言ってるの自分だけついて
いけてないんじゃないか語学力のハンデが
あるからダメなんじゃないかと勝手に劣等
感がんでそんなことなかったんですね彼ら
だって大学で学ぶ授業って初めてだから彼
らにとっても初めてのこと
だから自分は別にそんな劣等感感じる必要
ないんだなって気付かされたんです
それのお陰で私やってきたすごいいい
出会いでしたまあそんな風にですね色んな
出会いがあったんですけど今日みなさんに
お伝えしたいのがいろんな出会いがあった
中で私の人生に大きな影響を与えている
出会いというのはすべて私と全然違う考え
方とか違う経験
違う文化を持った人たちの出会いなんです
ね今までなかった視点をもたらしてくれる
からすごく大きな影響を与えてくれるん
ですね
ここに分けハプニン店リアル室ってなって
ますけど10年後何が起こりうるか
例えば10年前はた就職した10年前なん
ですその時スマホなんてなかったんですね
世の中に sns もなかった今当たり前
ですよね高校生の皆さんもしかしが持って
ますよね
じゃあこれから10年後どうなるか変化の
スピードさらに上がっていますもしかし
たら10年後皆さんが社会人になるとき今
想像をしてないような職種に就いているか
もしれない
今このように存在してない会社が就職
ランキング1位になってるかもしれない
それぐらい変わるんですそんな変化の時代
に皆さん何が求められると思いますが
どんなスキルを身につけなきゃいけないの
か
やって変化に対応できる柔軟性なんですね
いろんな変化が遅れる中で皆さんは柔軟性
が必要だ
その柔軟性を鍛えるにはどうしたらいいか
いろんな出会いを通じて自分の視野を
広げるしかないんです
留学ってそういう出会いに溢れてます
ぜひ皆さんもですねそういった出会い経験
っていうのを通じてですね視野を広げて
変化に対応できるそんな需要が柔軟性を
育てていきたいなとそんな風に思ってい
ます
ご静聴ありがとうございましたぜひベル町